foreign
is in Athens hey Emily welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey thank you I hope you're doing well
so my question for today is I have a
rental property that I owe fifty
thousand dollars on it and I want for my
future
um just to have an extra income I want
to know if it would be smart to get a
um the equity out of that rental
property to purchase either uh do a flip
investment or just to get another
property a rental property so I can have
that reoccurring income for the future
I wouldn't do that Emily
um if I were you I would
do you have a primary residence and if
so do you owe money on it
yes but the the thought is that we pay
off the rental property and in a couple
of years move into it and sell the house
that we are living in now because the
house that we're in now we purchased it
because you know we have a lot of kids
and soon you know they'll be out so what
do you owe on it
on our house now that we live in we owe
200 000.
okay but if you borrow on the rental
then you're going to move into a
property that has a mortgage on it
um so I kind of kind of feature idea
um what I'm in my head my
money correctly or not
you explained it you said I want to take
out a home equity loan or an equity line
of credit on the rental property to buy
more rental properties but I'm going to
move in the rental property later
because it's going to be paid for no it
won't you took out a home equity loan on
it and you your whole thing was you
wanted security and all you're doing is
taking on more debt
I mean so here's the thing okay Emily I
used to buy and sell real estate for a
living I've owned over 2 000 pieces of
property in my life I went bankrupt when
I was 28 years old doing the crap you're
talking about doing only I did it with
like 100 plus properties while you're
doing it with one so what I figured out
from that is that the shortest distance
between where you are and wealth and
security is not more borrowed money
borrowed money adds risk and stress to
your life and the chance of failure to
your life debt-free moves you the other
way and when you're debt free you don't
have any payments you have a cash flow
that's unbelievably wonderful
so if I were you I would work to get
both of these current properties paid
off and then if I wanted to buy more
rentals I would save up and pay for them
that doesn't move as fast as your plan
but it also doesn't wreck the car what
your plan can do
I'ma just tell you what Jade warshaw
would do I'd want my primary mortgage
paid free and clear when are you when
are you going to sell the current house
the one that I live in now yeah you said
you're going to sell it move into the
rental remember well that's in a couple
of years
a couple of years five or one no my kids
are still the oldest is 15. so I'm like
I said you know once they get how much
how old is the youngest
this is long long term I would this is
what Jade would do I would get rid of
this rental take the equity and pay off
my home because you're going to be in
there the next 10 years your kid is two
yep and then when you get that house
paid off if you want to buy some rentals
or do some flips you do them well she's
going to have extra money do them with
cash she's still gonna have money left
over so maybe they're you know you're
going to be there very so much faster
you can get another rental absolutely
cash absolutely that's what I would do
that's so opposite of what we what you
called about that you're not going to do
it but that is what you should do